irgendwas stimmt hier nicht ich weiß es
auch nicht naja aber dafür ist dass
fragen lotto überraschend wie immer die
ein oder andere wahrheit kommt ja ans
licht so auch mit sebastian madsen der
über das verhältnis zu seiner ex
freundin spricht und zwar ausgerechnet
bei der frage über welche themen sie
ungern sprechen ja so ist das manchmal
bei klick somit madsen jetzt das ist das
fragen motto wir haben uns harmlose
fragen und gemeinde fragen überlegt die
sind entsprechend gefärbt das eine ist
geht er ins rote das andere ins grüne
ihr könnt selber wählen ihr könnt so
viel ziehen wie ihr wollt
so like du eine ich eine ja ich mache
augen zu sehen obwohl diese wurde idee
nicht welche die gefährlichen sind
vielleicht typischerweise die grünen
hatten grün
ich habe grün soll ich mache dir inhalt
auch gefährlich weil oder schwierig zu
beantworten ist schwerer als die roten
weil sie so bauch pinseln sind haribo
netz unter ihr habt auf über 140
festivals gespielt wird das nicht
irgendwann zu langweilig diese frage
kann ich mit einem sehr überzeugt nein
antworten das kann überhaupt gar nicht
langweilig werden
und da da da legen wir auch unfassbar
viel wert drauf weil wir nicht immer das
gleiche spielen weil wir b nicht die ich
immer auf dem gleichen festival spielen
und da schon gar nicht die gleichen
leute davor stehen jedes konzert ob nun
festival oder club muss sein eigenes
haben und wir wollen das ist uns ganz
wichtig wie gesagt dass wir wieder uns
noch irgendjemand anderen langweilen
deswegen spielen wir auch nie zweimal
die gleiche setlist untereinander machen
immer wenn es eine kleine veränderung
ist wir wir verändern immer irgendwas
kommt natürlich durcheinander weil zwei
teile der band bei den anderen stücken
wie wir haben ja dann fast vorgestern
das geld überwies kellerbar lied ich bin
dann auch nicht davon abzubringen man
muss da diese medien und sagen sebastian
stopp ich bin so in meinem fehlen drin
ich lass mir niemanden dann irgendwas
erzählen schwierig okay aber sobald mir
langweilig wird auf einem festival tanz
studiert pädagogik weil das alles keinen
sinn mehr
verwechselt die war ja eher kritisch die
frage
ok jetzt komplette überraschung
beigetragen motto vielleicht sind rot
und grün auch verwechselt und man wiegt
sich in sicherheit wenn man grün ziel
werden sie jetzt ziehen werden von einer
umfrage auch findet oder ich weiß es
braucht pinsel oder der bock auf was
dieses das letzte album wurde im
wohnzimmer studio aufgenommen könnt ihr
euch nichts besseres leisten
also wir haben tatsächlich selber die
platte zum teil auch finanziert und wir
haben ein bisschen drauf geachtet auf
jeden fall das tat dem album aber auch
sehr gut weil beim labyrinth war es eben
so dass wir wahnsinnig viel zeit hatten
zeit zum weintrinken zeit zum
golfspielen ist es auch da haben kein
golf gestimmt ich hasse gold wollte den
fußstapfen der eagles treten sie waren
auch so drauf hat
ich glaube das hört sich die platten
können sie die platten land leben wir
wollten wir wollten unglaublich
fleißiges album machen also nehmen
fleißig ist das falsch also jetzt mit
neuen album das dass wir einfach total
viel geübt haben wieder und wir wollten
nicht ins studio gehen und dann erst
anfangen irgendwie an den songs zu
basteln und strukturen zu arbeiten
wir wollten das alles vorher klar ist
und deswegen kann es eigentlich eher
zufall deswegen wurden viele sachen aus
unserem heimstudio verwendet weil weil
wir dann beim bei den demos und schon so
viel mühe gegeben haben dass wir einfach
wussten dass kann ich oder bei manchen
text ich kann das nie wieder so singen
dass das kriegen auch nicht im fetten
studio in hamburg wo wir dann zum teil
auch sachen aufgenommen haben eben diese
live geschichten aber wem ganz viele
sachen wirklich aus dem proberaum
genommen woran liegt es dann dass du so
nie wieder hinkriegt
das ist das ist die stimmung und der
moment wenn man den mann einfängt wenn
das wenn das lied gerade frisch ist wenn
man wenn man gerade in der euphorie drin
ist sich jako-o thema und der texter
passt jetzt irgendwie so zur musik und
dann das ist das war perfektion so dass
wir über nacht baden so 0 0 hatten wir
noch nicht genug möglichkeiten dass das
dann wirklich auch auf die platte kommen
teilweise und jetzt war das endlich
möglich dass wir uns dass wir den luxus
hatten auszusagen
das ist jetzt ein jahr alt aber das war
das war so die stimmung war so
einzigartig in dem moment dass man das
nicht reproduzieren kann
und jetzt ist endlich sind wir bei uns
im heimstudio so weit dass die dass er
so gut klingt dass man das dann auch auf
die platte punkt das heißt ihr überhaupt
würden auch behaupten diese stimmung ist
auf die platte gekommen auf jeden fall
absolut und das ist dann auch im studio
man kennt ja diese
unsinnig großen streber mehr vorne mit
pop schutz davor weil viele sachen auf
dem album sind eben auch so gesanglich
entstanden dass ich in der regie stand
die boxen sind unfassbar aufgerissen so
dass wir genau und die über sprechen
dann über dieses sm 57 was ich hatte ein
ganz normales mikrofon was jede
amateuren hat da habe ich rein gesungen
post nicht glauben will
180 euro oder so und das aber das
irgendwie unverwechselbar mike skinner
des street erste der album alleine zu
hause aufgenommen im laptop die beats
die wackeln und alles sitzt überhaupt
nicht und irgendwie ist es aber so
charmant so dass es die beste platte von
ihm ist verendet wir müssen weitermachen
die haben nicht am ende wirklich am
besten
sex drugs und rock'n roll über was
würdet ihr nie in der öffentlichkeit
reden genau
also ich würde da vorher nichts
festlegen ich würde dann wenn es dann
soweit kommt und mir eine stahl frage
gestellt wird wo ich jetzt keine lust
habe die zu beantworten würde einfach
sagen ja das wild auf wild da möchte ich
jetzt bitte nicht darüber reden
ich glaube dass das aber so gut wie noch
nie vorgekommen ist weil wir über alles
reden oder nein weil man uns keine es
keine so und diskreten fragen nicht
keine ahnung wie wir in diesem bunte
gala kosmos oder ok das ist einfach mit
uns kann man im prinzip über alles reden
und visa schon sagte wir ziehen dann
irgendwann unsere grenzen wir merken
dass die beziehung zu seiner ex freundin
fragt dich so gut aber du hast du gesagt
denn es steht das schöne ist und da
kommen wir wieder zu den fans dass wir
da so dass wir da sehr glücklich sind
also da müssen wir wieder zu den fans
kommen wir können ein stinknormales
leben führen also bei sebastian ist es
manchmal so ein bisschen anders weise
das erkannt wird wenn er einkaufen geht
oder so aber selbst finden wenn wir wenn
wir zu viert oder zu sechs aufschlagen
und wohin gehen dann werden wir mal nach
dem foto gefragt oder nacht nach einem
autogramm haben dann aber unsere ruhe
und es irgendwie interessiert keinath
übertragen und irgendwie und unser
sexleben dass das will schon überhaupt
keiner wissen
und da sind wir auch über diesen status
die mir da haben und darauf wie wie
unaufgeregt und so fenster sind da sind
wir sehr dankbar für auch keine stalking
erfahrungen gemacht nie am anfang mal so
ganz bisschen so ansatzweise schmiedel
der source den freund und so lasst doch
und dann war's gut okay
kommt noch rot oder grün finale im
finale hatte ich auf diese lange
wunderbar bands haben auch sexy groupies
nutztier das aus 100 prozentig okay also
wie man deutlich bei rockstars
vorstellten nach dem konzert gibt es im
modell eine wilde party
es gibt ja leute tatsächlich bands die
schicken dann ihren pässen und die
suchen sich dann hübsche mädels und die
werden dann nach hinten geführt und
erstmal fühle ich mich zu alt dafür
dann bin ich fest vergeben dann
ansonsten was sie nicht will doch nicht
mit fremden leuten irgendwann anfangen
ist doch doof ich will doch erst mal das
gespräch aufbauen erst mal ein eis essen
gehen uns okay it's cool langsam liebe
und so genau echt obwohl er alle
möglichkeiten hätte ja aber die
möglichkeiten sind scheiße weil er
bringt einem nicht okay glaube ich so
das ist vielleicht mal kurz bestätigung
und dann weiß auch irgendwie traurig
weil die person wieder weg die kennt
dich gar nicht völlig falschen eindruck
von dir das macht glaube ich keinen spaß
also ich habe plötzlich ein interview
mit rolf eden geführt jetzt 82 jahr gut
der agent für was ganz anderes
er muss das auch machen der muss auch
mit 82 rubys abschleppen
okay da ist das ja auch völlig in
ordnung so wenn er das machen möchte und
da auch esther frauen auch gibt die sich
irgendwie dafür mädchen man muss sagen
wer junge naja das ist dann natürlich
grenzwertig aber seine freundin würde 30
ist schon viel zu allen freunden auch
schon bereit sich etwa 17
und auch bei pixum gewissen fragen lotto
haudegen sie sprechen darüber wann sie
weinen und der profi gamer guti der
erklärt und erzählt wie er mit profi
gaming um die welt kommt dass in diesen
beiden fragen lottos ihr könnt jetzt
gucken worauf er klickt viel spaß auf
jeden fall dabei bis dann bleibt dran